[Música]
al menos 50 personas cinco de ellas
niños perdieron la vida y alrededor de
un centenar resultaron heridas en medio
de un ataque con misiles contra la
estación de trenes de la ciudad
ucraniana de crematorios de miles de
ciudadanos esperaban poder evacuar la
zona rusia aseguró que no tiene
responsabilidad en los hechos
la presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen y el jefe de la
diplomacia del bloque joseph murray se
reunieron en kiev con el presidente
volodymyr selenski y aseguraron que se
necesitan más sanciones contra rusia
más temprano visitaron las fosas comunes
de la ciudad ucraniana de butch a
señalaron que pudieron presenciar la
cara más cruel del ejército ruso
el tiroteo perpetrado por un hombre
palestino ayer en israel deja tres
muertos hoy falleció uno de los heridos
que estaba en condición crítica y el
ejército israelí informó que mató al
atacante 14 personas han muerto en el
último mes en hechos similares ampliamos
desde jerusalén
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en ucrania donde al menos 50
personas entre ellas cinco menores
perdieron la vida tras un bombardeo con
misiles contra la estación de trenes de
cra motors ubicada en el este del país
en ese lugar se habían congregado miles
de ciudadanos que buscan huir del
donbass hacia zonas más seguras de
ucrania kiev washington y la unión
europea señalaron a rusia como
responsable pero desde el kremlin
aseguraron que no usan el tipo de
proyectiles con los que se realizó el
ataque
decenas de cadáveres amontonados unos
simples plásticos los protegen de la
vista del público los charcos de sangre
y la tierra quemada completan la escena
aquí en la estación de trenes de grama
torch son las consecuencias de uno de
los peores ataques contra civiles desde
que comenzó la guerra las autoridades
ucranianas acusan a rusia
la estación central de trenes de cra
motors fue alcanzada por un misil de
crucero tipo 2 kv con munición de racimo
[Música]
se han confirmado decenas de muertes en
los ataques con misiles y los heridos
fueron trasladados al hospital
grabadas todo explotó de repente y
muchas personas murieron
esta mujer acaba de enterarse de que uno
de sus familiares ha muerto
y este hombre acababa de llegar con su
abuela cuando se produjo la explosión
vamos
acabo de sacar su cuerpo sin vida del
coche había ido a comprar cigarrillos
así y la bomba estalló y vi que mi
abuela estaba muerta corrí a rescatar a
la gente que estaba más lejos
las milicias pro rusas de donges han
acusado a kiev de dicho bombardeo
tildándolo de provocación mientras que
el kremlin negó que las tropas rusas
utilicen el tipo de misiles empleados en
el ataque y acusaron a los ucranianos de
haber atacado deliberadamente la
estación de tren
aquí se debe confiar en la declaración
del ministerio de defensa que excluye el
uso de este misil por parte de las
fuerzas armadas rusas nuestras fuerzas
armadas no usan misiles de este tipo no
hubo misiones de combate en grama torch
y ninguna ha sido programada para hoy
debemos confiar en esta declaración el
alcalde de crematorio dijo que unas 4000
personas se encontraban en la estación
cuando cayeron los misiles allí se
preparaban para evacuar a regiones más
seguras mientras rusia concentra sus
tropas en el este de ucrania la
presidenta de la comisión europea a
ursula von der leyen y el alto
representante para la política exterior
del bloque joseph murray se reunieron en
kiev con el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski y resaltaron la
necesidad de sanciones más fuertes
contra rusia la funcionaria se
comprometió a ofrecer a ucrania un
comienzo más rápido en la candidatura de
esa nación para convertirse en miembro
de la unión europea esto dijo sobre las
nuevas sanciones
estamos movilizando nuestro poder
económico para que putin pague un precio
alto hemos impuesto cinco olas de
sanciones sin precedentes contra rusia y
estamos preparando la próxima serie van
a atacar el corazón de rusia por ejemplo
las exportaciones han sido reducidas un
71 por ciento la inflación está 20 por
ciento en rusia la confianza de las
empresas está su nivel más bajo desde
1995 pruebe al encuentro a los altos
funcionarios europeos visitaron la
localidad ucraniana de butch a donde
recientemente fueron hallados cientos de
cuerpos de civiles en fosas comunes
escoltados por militares ucranianos
recorrieron las calles de la ciudad
estuvieron junto a los cuerpos
recientemente exhumados
la oficina humanitaria de la onu anunció
que está trasladando ayuda hacia el este
de ucrania y planea enviar varias
caravanas hacia las regiones de donettes
y lugansk la próxima semana aunque de
acuerdo con los responsables todo
depende de las condiciones sobre el
terreno el donbass es considerado por la
onu como el área de mayor preocupación
en materia humanitaria recordemos que
los ataques del ejército ruso
actualmente se concentran precisamente
en el este del país
we tried to put it in vamos a intentar
hacer llegar la ayuda en la medida de lo
posible la gente sigue refugiada en los
sótanos de donges kill ones tenemos en
nuestra planificación convoyes para ir
allí tengo entendido que la próxima
semana de nuevo si eso sucede o no
depende de la situación de seguridad
pero estará listo para ir allí si
podemos entrar el ataque en grama torch
del cual las partes se acusan mutuamente
llega un día después de que las
autoridades ucranianas advirtieran a los
residentes del donbass que estaban ante
su última oportunidad para escapar en el
este de ucrania los civiles que intentan
huir de los ataques de las fuerzas rusas
cuentan con ayuda de bolt los ciudadanos
comunes que extienden una mano para
aquellos que no pueden salir por sus
propios medios más detalles en el
siguiente reporte
el teléfono de este hombre no para de
sonar en qué parte de la ciudad está
usted al otro lado de la línea personas
le ruegan que vaya a buscarlos
alexei para believe acude regularmente a
se viera daniel para evacuar a los
civiles una ciudad que está bajo el
intenso fuego de las fuerzas rusas y
martín a
tengan cuidado con los grandes
los cracks son cohetes que han estado
disparando contra los ucranianos desde
el comienzo de la guerra alexei es
taxista pero ha optado por transportar a
la gente gratuitamente mientras dure la
guerra
no tenemos que tomar las armas ni
unirnos a la defensa del territorio hay
otras formas de ayudar
aquí están las personas que llevarán y
pro la ciudad más segura al oeste
decidió vender su coche para comprar
esta furgoneta aunque no es tan cómoda
es como un milagro para sus pasajeros
pensaba que estaría bien aquí pero no es
así en absoluto lo siento es muy
aterrador últimos prox
otros los residentes abrazan
calurosamente a su héroe una especie de
ángel de la guarda llamado a la acción
en medio del peligro
separada me es que es la ciudad más
apartado del este del país que sigue
bajo control ucraniano es un objetivo
constante para los invasores y las
autoridades quieren que todos los
civiles se vayan en la furgoneta el
alivio que sienten estos dos hombres es
palpable han recuperado la esperanza y
propietarios en el primero iraní pero y
después ya veré a dónde me lleva el
destino
el taxista le da combustible a esta
mujer porque no queda más en la
gasolinera en serbia dónetsk ya no hay
agua en los grifos sino que la
distribuye en los bomberos los
habitantes de la ciudad no tienen acceso
al gas ni a la electricidad desde el
comienzo de la guerra
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia serguéi lávrov propuso que el
vecino belarús sea uno de los garantes
en los diálogos de paz que adelanta con
ucrania
recordemos que belarús se prestó para
albergar tropas rusas que ingresaron en
ucrania y que el presidente de ese país
alexandr lukashenko es uno de los
principales aliados de vladimir putin
gracias a pedido de la parte ucraniana a
su condicional neutral no nuclear debe
ir acompañada de garantías de seguridad
para ucrania entre los garantes de la
seguridad a los vecinos de ucrania les
gustaría ver a todos los países
adyacentes y a varios otros países
incluidos los miembros permanentes del
consejo de seguridad etcétera por lo que
propusimos que belarús sea uno de los
garantes de seguridad todos estos
asuntos incluida la lista completa de
los países garantes se están aprobando
pero apoyamos que belarús sea uno de
ellos
y los precios de los alimentos a nivel
mundial alcanzaron en marzo su mayor
nivel desde
1990 por el encarecimiento de los
aceites vegetales y los cereales así lo
informó la organización de la onu para
la alimentación y la agricultura que
explicó que la guerra en ucrania ha
elevado los costos del trigo la cebada y
el maíz ya que rusia y ucrania son
grandes exportadores de estos productos
además de vender conjuntamente el 52 por
ciento del aceite de girasol que se
consume en el mundo previamente
conversamos con maya está calle líder
del programa regional de la fao que nos
explicó cuáles son las regiones más
afectadas y qué pasa en américa latina
en particular
todo el mundo de una manera es afectado
pero principalmente el norte de áfrica y
países de asia que dependen muchísimo de
las exportaciones de cereales y aceites
de los granos o son muy fuertemente
afectados en la región a la región toda
nuestra región de américa latina y el
caribe es dependiente
de importaciones de fertilizantes porque
además de exportar los cereales también
son regiones que exportan euros y que
dan son dos países que exportan mucho
los fertilizantes y ahí está nuestro
riesgo entonces no hay país quien no
será afectado por el tema no solamente
de las importaciones que depende
dependemos de estos países pero también
de los mismos en israel falleció uno de
los heridos del tiroteo registrado el
jueves en tel aviv lo que eleva la cifra
de víctimas a 3 en ese hecho el deceso
se produce el mismo día en que la
policía israelí anunció que capturó y
mató al autor del ataque desde jerusalén
federico que barberena corresponsal de
france 24 nos dio más detalles el
atentado del jueves en tel aviv se cobra
una tercera víctima para club fan de 35
años si ese entrenador paralímpico de
kayak israelí falleció por sus heridas
según informó el hospital ichilov donde
se encontraba internado así ya son 14
los muertos por cuatro atentados en poco
más de dos semanas en israel
este último impacto en particular por
haber sido en una zona céntrica de tel
aviv y porque el atacante logró fugarse
9 horas duró las búsquedas para hasta
dar con su paradero de los cuatro
ataques este es el segundo perpetrado
por un palestino otra vez de la zona de
yenín en el norte de cisjordania donde
se encuentra un campo de refugiados que
en los últimos días en los últimos días
había sido objeto de violentas redadas
el gobierno de natalie benítez promete
ampliar las operaciones y dispuso
también el bloqueo del cruce de silbo a
salame en el norte de cisjordania
también se multiplicaron los controles
en jerusalén para el primer viernes de
rezos del ramadán que transcurrió sin
incidentes en la mezquita de al-aqsa el
agresor de 28 años no tenía antecedentes
en ni vínculos conocidos con
organizaciones aunque tanto hamás como
la yihad islámica saludaron en ataque
sin adjudicárselo su padre un ex oficial
de seguridad palestino celebró la acción
de su hijo frente a decenas de vecinos
en su casa por el contrario el
presidente de la autoridad palestina
mahmud abbas condenó la matanza de
civiles israelíes y dijo que eso
de lograr la estabilidad vamos ahora
hasta teherán la capital iraní donde la
contaminación del aire está alcanzando
niveles alarmantes la ciudad amaneció
con una densa capa que cubre el cielo y
proviene de irak la situación llevó al
despliegue de los servicios de
emergencia en las calles las autoridades
meteorológicas
informaron que la calidad del aire es
insalubre para todos los grupos y que en
algunos horarios alcanzarán niveles
peligrosos por lo que pidieron a la
gente que suspenda sus actividades al
aire libre
desde la casa blanca la próxima jueza de
la corte suprema estadounidense que tang
yi brawn jackson celebró su confirmación
por parte del senado en un acto con el
presidente joe biden y la vicepresidenta
kamala harris la jurista se comprometió
a que una vez asuma el cargo realizará
su trabajo con independencia el
mandatario elogió su carácter e
integridad braun jackson entrará al
tribunal como la primera mujer afro en
esa corte luego de que el juez stephen
breyer deje su cargo
el presidente colombiano iván duque
firmó la extradición a eeuu de dairo
antonio úsuga alias otoniel el antiguo
máximo jefe del clan del golfo con el
decretó su traslado al país
norteamericano que lo requiere por
delitos de narcotráfico será efectiva en
cualquier momento alias otoniel tiene
122 órdenes de captura y 6 sentencias
condenatorias en colombia entre ellas
dos de 40 y 50 años de prisión por
homicidio agravado homicidio en persona
protegida desaparición forzada
desplazamiento forzado y reclutamiento
ilícito de menores
y despegó desde cabo cañaveral sexual la
primera misión tripulada privada que
llevará astronautas a la estación
espacial internacional la misión está
liderada por el ex astronauta de la nasa
de origen español michael lópez-alegría
y la conforman otros tres civiles de
eeuu canadá e israel
los expertos viajaron en una cápsula
dragón y en un cohete falcon line las
insignias de la compañía spacex estarán
en la instalación durante ocho días
les recordamos que este domingo 10 de
abril tendremos un especial sobre la
primera vuelta de las presidenciales
francesas más de 48 millones de
ciudadanos galos están llamados a las
urnas pueden conectarse con nosotros a
partir del mediodía hora de bogotá quito
y lima
fin de la emisión volvemos en breve con
más noticias en france 24
[Música]